مع اختلاف طبيعه مثول الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب امام المحكمه بتهم
جنائيه واحداث الكابيتول الا ان هناك
مخاوف من تكرار ذات السيناريو فوضى وعنف
وتخريب رغم ان مؤشرات ذلك قليله وفقا
للسلطات الامنيه الامريكيه لكن لمعرفه
الاختلافات بين المناسبتين يجب اولا
التذكير باحداث الكابيتول
شغب الكابيتول حدث عام 2021 حين اقدم حشد
عنيف من انصار الرئيس دونالد ترامب على
مهاجمه مبنى الكابيتول في العاصمه واشنطن
احداث فتحت معها اكبر تحقيق في تاريخ
وزاره العدل الامريكيه ويواجه اكثر من 930
شخصا اتهامات بارتكاب جرائم فيدراليه
الامر المشترك ما بين احداث الكابيتول
وبين مثول ترامب امام المحكمه بقضايا
جنائيه هو خطاب الرئيس الامريكي السابق
لمناصريه لكن المختلف هو توقيت الخطابين
في احداث الكابيتول كان خطابه ناريا
ظهر فيه قبل ساعات من الواقعه واثار
المئات من انصاره اما فيما يتعلق بمحاكمته
في منهات فاعلن الرئيس الامريكي انه سيظهر
علنا بخطاب لكن هذه المره بعد ساعات من
سماعه لائحه الاتهام الموجهه له فحوى
الخطاب غير معروفه حتى الان لكن المعروف
هو تاثير ترامب على انصاره وفي المقابل
ردات الفعل غير المتوقعه للمناهضين له
احداث الكابيتول مثلت درسا للسلطات
الامنيه بدات بعدها بمسح امني واسع
للمشاركين وتبادل المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
بشكل اسرع وعلى الارض تجهيز مواقع الحدث
بحواجز معدنيه واغلاق الطرق وحتى قوى
بشريه ضخمه تغطي مساحه واسعه استعدادا لاي
طارئ